[Musique]
qu'écrire de neuf à propos du sida les
œuvres fondatrices de Michael pollac
d'Hervé Gibert et de quelques autres ont
cerné le coefficient social et émotif de
la maladie dans la fure du monde publiée
chez flamarion André gluxman s'efforce
d'en dessiner le contour philosophique
sans renoncer au passage à s'étonner de
certaines aberrations comment se fait-il
par exemple qu'il est fallu 10 années
pour abaisser de façon significative le
prix des préservatifs c'est que la
fonction de la bureaucratie comme le dit
bien gluxman est l'annulation des
inquiétudes le sida est une défaite de
cette immunité considérée comme acquise
depuis pasteur c'est une injure à la
science médicale qui ronge le lien
social décrète la méfiance de l'autre
incite à la répression à l'enfermement
dès lors comment penser la maladie
est-elle une nouvelle tuberculose qui
porte paradoxalement à l'exaltation de
ce moi contaminé puisque être homme
c'est être malade et ne déclenche-t-elle
pas d'autre part cette peur de la peur
obsession silencieuse génératrice de
tous les égoïsmes celui du corps médical
mis en cause et celui des malades
persécutés c'est que le sida à l'instar
de la antise atomique fait vaciller
l'univers
[Musique]